they're they're either on autopilot or
they're just looking out for their jobs
i have been in situations where i have
worked with other
specific networks and there's these
execs who have either slandered
slandered misconstrued stuff that i said
because they [ __ ] up
just to cover their back and i have to
go in through an email and be like hold
on a second
that's not how it [ __ ] is this is
what it's like because they're looking
out for their own you know bunch of
snakes though you know i mean
i think um anybody who's had any
experience in
entertainment industry is i'm almost 100
sure this video is already demonetized
[ __ ] 15 seconds welcome everybody to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast this is a podcast about anything
and everything and we got
uh two very special guests here we have
ray one of my childhood
friends yes sir since sacramento and he
and i grow
two very different people uh
ray if you guys don't know he does uh
sound [ __ ]
so i don't know what the exact title of
your job is right but he does sound [ __ ]
so anytime i've had a sketch done or
whatever that needed to be processed
and you guys were very critical about
the way the the audio sounded that's his
fault
that's ray's fault then we got khalif in
the house and we also have ed park ed
two do you like to be called edric or ed
i mean both you know it doesn't matter
the the reason why i tell people
my name is ed is because they butcher my
name when i say edric what do you say
like is they're like oh eric like no
edric oh andrew no no edrick
no so like because you know most of the
time well pre-covered days right
yeah a lot of the times when you're in a
social setting there's some you know
background noise going on right whether
you're at a bar or at a club whatever
and you're meeting people and then it's
like oh you know my name is edric nice
to meet you and then
they just like it's like strike three
strike four straight i'm like
you know what they just call me ed you
know and they go ethel yeah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah that's why like
they'll make up names too like i mean
granted edrick is a pretty unique name
right but
like they'll make up names like edrin
you know i'm like all right it's from
edgeridge
so that's why i got in the habit of like
introducing myself as ed
just to kind of keep it easy because
like i started to get a little irritated
i don't want to
keep repeating myself like no edric no
no
you just take it into the bathroom and
just choking them
say my [ __ ] name
the worst was though was that i never
anticipated
anybody messing up like ed right i mean
it's a [ __ ] two-letter name right
i went to a mcdonald's one time and then
they said oh what's the name on the
order
i said ed okay and they call my order
and they're like i gotta order for uh
ed erectile dysfunction
come on man it's not that
hard man that you looked up he's
actually blind
but that would have been pretty terrible
even if you spit in my food i won't be
mad anymore no but
i was like dude how do you [ __ ] up ed
like that's come on man
just [ __ ] stupid man with the name
stuff because i've been
i've been noticing like when people ask
me what my name is i'm like
it's in my mind i surprise myself either
i'm gonna say
cliff or khalifa yeah yeah i don't even
know what i'm gonna say when i say
i'm like khalif i'm like they're gonna
[ __ ] this yeah yeah like khalid i'm like
yeah
that's pretty good that's actually
pretty close you know sometimes people
always say
khalid and there's a there's a [ __ ] f
at the end of it every time i see him
order a drink yeah
without fail seventy percent of the time
yeah yeah
why i mean because it's you know it's
it's it's a pretty
rare name too but but here's the thing
though it's cal lid
versus eve like a leaf
did you [ __ ] say somebody said queef
yeah let me speak to your manager well
today's topic uh
i think we should talk about this and i
just had uh uh
edna over here
so chappelle if you guys don't know dave
chappelle actually has
an instagram which ed didn't even i
don't even know i just found out like
right when i got here
so not too long ago chappelle opened up
an instagram i don't know if it was
because of his idea
or i don't know somebody else told him
to open one but he doesn't post
often and it's it's it's only small
little clips of certain things right so
i think he has a total of maybe eight
posts within the past year
but things that you do get to see on his
instagram he'll post these small little
specials
so he posted one recently uh what was it
titled again unforgiven
unforgiven right and there was uh when i
was looking around people were
people were quoting [ __ ] from the
chappelle stuff but i didn't know what
the [ __ ] it meant and i remember i just
made a joke at my friend he
he posted on his instagram he wrote uh
something about he made a comment about
hot dogs like people
you don't know what goes in hot dogs but
you still eat them or some [ __ ] it was
like a chapel quote right
i [ __ ] dm this fall i was like [ __ ]
you hot dogs are delicious
what the [ __ ] because he's trying to be
all cool and artsy and [ __ ] yeah he's
like you didn't watch the chapel she was
like no
this [ __ ] just came out i'm like how the
[ __ ] am i supposed to know what that
means
but chappelle does uh i'm not sure if
you can really call it stand up
yeah maybe he did the stand-up portion
and this was the last part story time by
chappelle
story time which i [ __ ] love it was
so good and it was interesting when
now when i watch chappelle do this stuff
it's
we were talking about how i arguably
like it better than his previous stand
up which made him so iconic in our lives
right because when i when i go back and
i watch the previous dave chappelle
stuff
it's very kevin hart-esque meaning that
it's super loud
there aren't a lot of gaps in in his
stand-up
so there's no breathing room and it's
just joke after joke after joke which i
think when you're young
you like that [ __ ] it's like the stuff
that a lot of young people like about
youtube videos and vine
it's gratuitous laughs it's quick bing
bang boom
right right but when you watch the
chappelle stuff he takes time to think
and we as an audience
um we allow him to think yeah we're not
thinking oh this is
his set's going bad you know so when i
watch when i watch his stuff and
it ends i'm always like wanting more
which is weird because
it's not really a stand-up set for sure
you know for sure no you see
i think like the biggest thing for me is
and what i appreciate about that is you
see kind of the evolution of an artist
you know and he's just getting more and
more masterful with this craft
and the thing about dave is that he has
this
ability to draw you in into his story
and and then like make you imagine what
what that world was like that he's
speaking about
right so that's that's always indicative
of a masterful storyteller
right even if it's false even if it
never happened
the way he tells the story and the way
he basically
structures it you know because it always
comes back to something
and so whether it's a punch line or
there's a central theme
like you never know how he's gonna weave
in and out of that sometimes
he'll go on a really serious tone and
you'll see a rant like just a random
punch on you like
i was not expecting that but that's
[ __ ] hilarious right he started off
series making you think he's here and
then other times
he'll just take you on that serious pat
which is what that instagram clip was
like right
um yeah i mean and so like for me
it's when i when i'm watching this guy
and listening to this guy on stage
it doesn't feel like he's performing a
set yeah it just it feels more intimate
than that
it feels like your friend's talking to
you yeah yeah or or at the least
like somebody who you
admire and respect sharing kind of their
life experience with you teaching you
yeah yeah
learning from that right um and so it's
i think that's a really cool um kind of
evolution to see because like
we all were fans of the chappelle show
and this is exactly what he's talking
about right i mean
chappelle's show was such a big part of
like
i guess well for me my college days um
and
and at that time it was such a big part
of pop culture
you had chappelle references all day
all day right what did the five fingers
say to their face
man i slapped so many people for no
[ __ ] reason because
yeah i love that [ __ ] i just start
smacking people out in public yeah and
they would still laugh
rick james [ __ ] [ __ ] your couch right
oh [ __ ] your couch was that [ __ ] yeah so
like yeah it was such a big part of
pop culture at the time and then you
know you had the whole
um kind of the uh collapse of the
chappelle show by dave taking off right
and there was a mystery there's a lot of
mystery surrounding that did this guy
actually go crazy
was he on drugs was he mentally unstable
and then
little by little ever since he's come
back into the public space
he's been shedding a little bit more
light on it a little bit more and gives
you more context
20 it was like 20 odd years he didn't
say anything right and he kind of let
people say whatever they wanted about
him
yeah i could not do that yeah like the
moment i hear something false like he
was telling
somebody made a comment about one of my
lights
immediately and he was like yo if i
would do it this way and i'm like that's
funny you're a nobody now go [ __ ]
yourself
i don't have to say that that person was
probably a fan
not anymore but you know dave chappelle
just kind of said [ __ ] it i'm not a part
of this space and i'm going to let you
guys think what you want to think
and he was talking about even in the
special how he had accusations that he
was doing cocaine and he was devout
muslim
crack smoking crap crap yeah all right
angel does pcp yeah he was smoking
crackers
just go come on son and then
but you know and he let those rumors
kind of just
go about and you know i'm pretty sure it
was really hurtful right because he was
doing something that in his mind he
thought was
a rightful thing to do yeah but people
just looked at him like he's a crazy
person he went to africa he left 50
million [ __ ] dollars why would
somebody do this
if he's not crazy but you look at it
from his perspective when he speaks
and when uh if you guys watched too he
recently went on the letterman show the
one that's on netflix as well yeah
same platform right and he talks about
the sketch and i actually went back to
watch the chappelle show on netflix my
bad dave yeah
before i didn't know this [ __ ] i thought
you knew about it man like we're best
friends don't don't
you know just pick up my text but he he
talked about how
it was that fairy because at the last
season when he left mid-season
it was uh charlie murphy and it was
daniel rollins
that were showing that fairy clip and
they had an open discussion with the
crowd
about what it means to them is it
defensive is it taking it too far in
terms of racism right yeah
because when you look at the clip it's
like this it's like a racial fairy right
doing like racial stereotypes there was
a black person there was there was an
asian fairy a mexican fairy there was a
white fairy
right and the thing that made dave
chappelle upset was
he was trying to say something with the
sketch and people were laughing for the
wrong reasons right
and so he goes oh am i actually doing a
disservice when i thought that i was
shedding light on something that i
wanted to talk about
right and it was dope because when you
see the crowd interaction people were
like
well when when you had the white fairy
you're making these stereotypical jokes
about white people
that's not really bad you they have
money they have power they make fun of
other ethnicities how are these negative
traits versus the asian people it's
ching chong ching chong
yeah the the black people is this this
and that and he goes
goes like hold on let me show you the
other second clip of it then and it's
literally the white fairy game pissed on
so now what do you think but it was it's
it's
it's such an integrity move right yeah
and even for me when i was younger
i believed in that [ __ ] i was oh he's
definitely doing coke or some [ __ ]
because who would walk away for 50
million dollars
for an average folk i mean it's hard to
to fathom right it's like
how can you walk away from that type of
money that type of fame like dude you're
the biggest thing in the comedy scene
right now
i mean it doesn't make sense to us but
we didn't have we weren't working with
all the information
right and he's finally shedding light on
the entire situation
and then now you're like oh and he was
young yeah for sure he was young
oh yeah he was super [ __ ] yeah he was
young i mean that's
what arguably uh catapulted him right to
to
like the beginning of dave chappelle
this major
mega comedian right that everybody knows
and so
prior to that he wasn't a household name
you know and so like that was even
a bigger reason why it was hard to
understand like dude you're now like
the [ __ ] you know yeah like everybody
knows you you're hilarious everybody
loves you why would you walk away
but now he's has a call to action to
people like
hey have you ever cared about me or ever
enjoyed something from me that was
yeah that's powerful because because now
he has that equity with the people
he has that trust he has that respect
and it's unanimous
he said that yeah nobody ever looks at
dave and goes oh that guy's whack or
you've heard like people
speaking ill of dave right so now he has
that power
and i thought that was really cool to
see that
he's using a platform where there's so
much
temporary just like vapid content that's
out there
to like put out something genuine and
he's like okay i'm gonna use this
platform
for for my cause and ultimately
like saying our cause so it was really
cool i i thought the whole thing was
have you guys seen uh george carlin's
stand up
i mean i've seen it but like which one
like well
i'm making that comparison because
there's like early george carlin yeah
yeah and i only found out about george
carlin maybe about like six or seven
years ago
i've heard of george carlin's name but i
was never a hardcore
connoisseur of stand-up comedy i had the
standard people that i liked that i
wanted to follow growing up it was
it was uh eddie murphy right dave
chappelle obviously there was bobby lee
and um of course bobby lee i [ __ ]
loved bobby lee yeah oh and airy spears
those were like my four top favorite
comedians right other than that anybody
else who to stand up i didn't watch that
much stand up
i watched a little bit here and there i
saw ray romano stuff i saw uh
kevin james stuff here and there but i
never uh got to see richard pryor stuff
that much and i only saw that maybe like
a few years back
and then uh but george carlin kind of
has the
dave chappelle i mean has the evolution
of what george carlin has because when
george carlin started off he was more
loud and robust with the stand-up comedy
and if you see towards his later years
before he passed away it was more dave
dave chappelle kind of has that same for
sure i could see the parallels
you know i mean like it's it's i want to
say it's preachy
but he also takes those moments where it
doesn't sound like he's performing a
stand-up joke where he's looking for
bits and punch lines
you know it's just it's a funny
conversation and funny thought
this podcast is brought to you by
another podcast called yo
is this racist do you ever hear
something and wondered to yourself
hey was that racist each wednesday the
show yo is as racist tries to answer
that question it's hosted by andrew t
and tony newsom who you probably know
from all your favorite earwolf shows
in each episode tony and andrew cover
racism in recent news and pop culture
and they answer burning questions from
fan submitted voicemails
about your maybe racist co-workers from
friends and family members
their guests include a huge range of
actors writers and comedians like
atsuko okatsuka nicole byer the scam
goddess lacey
mosley and even your childhood hero
levar burton
listen and subscribe to yo is this
racist on stitcher apple podcast
or on your favorite podcast app
and i see a lot of the i see those like
similarities you know
yeah i mean the biggest thing about dave
is just how insightful this guy is
how intelligent he is and and that's why
having the gift of gab that he has right
that
he's such a masterful storyteller
because he's
combining all of those strengths of his
and then funneling it through one craft
and then you just see a master at work
when he does it like every time
he's on stage whether it's funny or
serious or whatever it is
i'm always in awe i'm like this guy is a
[ __ ] goat no
question you know um it's this posture
is his body move like you just tell like
confidence yeah yeah yeah commanding
yeah um with the cigarette it's like oh
we're about to get rid of something
right and and and
and you could also tap tap tap
his voice has a lot more character in it
now too because he's a lot of older and
he's been smoking for a lot
he's got a lot of weirdest in his voice
that's part of it though right it's
captivating
um there's a certain like cadence that
he has and so
it's just like yeah you can't you can't
emulate what he does even if you try
like even if you had some of the skills
like it's
a perfect melting pot of all those
skills combined
well his comedy too is so uh what's the
it's like
fearless like i don't i don't know what
the word i'm looking for is but it is
fearless because he doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah he doesn't give up unlike uh kevin
hart
yeah he really no [ __ ] giving for sure
listen like before you know i'll we'll
talk about this topic too i
i personally love kevin hart i've
actually been to three of his stand-up
comedy specials
[ __ ] hilarious like the the energy
and vibe that he gives out when he
performs live and you're sitting there
it's way different i think there's a few
things that i've seen you know from
this is from a fan's perspective right
is that um
a lot of us then later on started to
feel either less personal or extremely
watered down
right it was different from the first
stuff that i saw and you know it's hard
to follow up
on those stand-up on the stand-up that
you do in the beginning that makes you
so popular
because the follow-up is always it's a
sequel part like the sequels are always
the most difficult right
except for dave chappelle which he's
like a rare commodity in this space
but when i saw his stand up uh it just
like his recent one called it's called
it's titled no [ __ ] given
when you have a title and you put your
stand up as no [ __ ] given when you're
already your prior your previous image
to that
is that you give way too many [ __ ] you
stay out of stuff that's political
you stay out of stuff that's
controversial because you want either
everybody to like you or you're afraid
that you're gonna lose brands and
endorsements
that's what kevin hart is known for now
kevin hart is a business man he's a
comedic rock star because he knows how
to navigate through this stuff
but in the conversation a stand-up it's
very rare and few and far between that
somebody says yo
kevin hart has some of the best stand-up
i've ever heard
i have yet to hear that in front of my
peers or anybody else to me growing up
i loved his [ __ ] but when i saw
his new special and said no [ __ ] given
i actually got excited i was like yo
this is going to be kevin hart
really showing out because he talks
about his reverence for dave chappelle
so high yeah right he talks about people
like george carlin
richard pryor these are these are gods
in the comedy space
eddie murphy and you saw what they did
on the stage right they didn't give a
[ __ ]
right which i think for comedy you can't
give a [ __ ] to a certain
extent so when he did no [ __ ] given and
i saw it and i watched it all the way
through
there was moments that i smile on the
smirk but i was like where was the part
where you didn't give a [ __ ]
like where was it i didn't see it you
know and
his his jokes were funny i watched it a
second time i always give it a second
try and i laughed more on the second
time i watched in the first one
because as an audience when he titled it
no [ __ ] given and he gave that
watered-down just very soft-serve type
of stand-up
not to say his material was whack but it
was like it wasn't
what the title was supposed to represent
this ain't raw yeah it left me wanting
more yeah you know so in my mind i'm
like why did you say that is it just
because you did your stand up in your
living room and you talked about your
ex-wife
that doesn't make that doesn't mean
there was no [ __ ] given like i don't
understand why you titled it that i mean
because
cause uh he's at a point now where he's
a
multi-faceted businessman right like he
he has his hands in all types of [ __ ]
and so it's
marketing ploy right i mean you you say
no [ __ ] given you think oh man
he's gonna he's gonna go ham he's gonna
you know say
anything and everything without any
reservation and then it gets people kind
of
curious or excited and then you tune in
and you're like oh
that's why i got bamboozled i think i
have bamboo
because the hard part what people try to
do when they when they follow somebody
like a dave chappelle or the comics who
don't who quote unquote don't really
give a [ __ ]
is that they forget that when dave
chappelle doesn't give a [ __ ] he
explains his thoughts thoroughly
like you said he takes you on this
journey that gets to the punch line or
the joke or what he's trying to portray
yeah there's a lot of other comics i'm
not gonna name them but they're bigger
comics
who just say crazy [ __ ] just to say
crazy [ __ ] ah
and then and they and they do the wow
factor thing but they're not saying
anything and then they get flamed for it
and they go well unlimited yeah it's
like well i'm just doing comedy it's
like well there's comedy but you still
have to
make it funny yeah and you're not doing
that you think you're doing what dave
chappelle's doing but you're not doing
what chappelle's doing because chappelle
is actually a great storyteller and he's
doing his job as a comic you're just
saying [ __ ] for the wow factor yeah
and and uh i think also too something to
consider
about dave is that he's only getting
better with time
which is very crazy yeah rarely do you
he's lebron yeah rarely do you see
somebody at their peak continuing and
extending that peak
having longevity with it right at a
certain point
um there's probably the argument that
once you become
too successful you kind of lose that
hunger and that drive
and then you start to see that reflected
in whatever the body of work is whether
you're an
athlete or a comedian whatever right and
then like
unless you're a special breed like a
kobe or mj where you just have this
maniacal drive to be the best
all the time even though you have all
the accolades it doesn't matter
your your goal is to be the best when
you're out there
not everybody has that type of dna not
everybody has that type of like maniacal
drive
and and somebody like dave i don't think
has that maniacal drive
but he again he just doesn't care he's
like
this is who i am this is what i want to
talk about
this is how i'm going to do it you know
and i think
it's the kind of the culmination of like
all his life experiences and
especially what he went through with
comedy central and the whole fallout
with that
that he is able to do what he's doing
and how he does it
and it just happens to be the perfect
time
in history where where the the media
outlets
like he doesn't need to go to a network
in order to get this [ __ ] out he could
just put it out himself
and then make his [ __ ] 20 mil by
giving netflix [ __ ] that he already had
in the
in the vault right and so i i feel like
it's just a combination of things and
and everything in the universe just
lined up where dave chappelle is able to
beat dave chappelle
well it's so weird because now these
media outlets and these execs that are
working there they actually have to be
responsible for the [ __ ] that they say
to people for sure because they never
had to before right
even people who are heads of these like
stand-up comedy stuff right there
there were so many gatekeepers that
stopped you from being successful
simply because people just either didn't
like the way you looked there was
somebody else that they wanted to push
in front of you
well those gatekeepers are now gone
right not gone completely
i want to be careful when i say that
there's still a bunch of gatekeepers
there right especially when you come
into the entertainment space that you
want to get signed to certain agencies
whatever that it is right but the cool
thing is when somebody who is like
dave chappelle or who has coveted i just
spit it out i don't know i saw that
directly so with somebody like dave
chappelle who has such a huge following
he doesn't need to wait for your [ __ ]
permission to drop a [ __ ] special
he'll do it like he did on put it on
[ __ ] instagram exactly
does it matter yeah you know and i think
that was the hardest part for me and
that's why when youtube came around and
all this other stuff it i was i said
okay well if i'm gonna be in school and
do all this other stuff and
when i'm trying to do these uh hit up
these comedy clubs and only giving me
five minutes
i'm gonna do something else and i'm
gonna try to put it on this platform and
it was a way better move that i made
than to just go to the comedy club and
hope to make
make it break it yeah yeah and and again
it's it's like just uh
being with the times right it's not like
dave chappelle is this super
technologically savvy guy and he's
talking about that type of stuff but
he recognizes the tools that he has to
work with and he works with it
and it makes it work for him and like i
said it just so happened
that it's the perfect time where how he
wants to do it
there's infrastructure in place to
facilitate that and he's able to execute
on it however he wants
and in the process he's making a lot of
money too
let's let's not forget netflix would pay
them 20 mil per special
right oh something ridiculous yeah so he
got 40 mil just just
and he's like i got more in the balls
yeah he has so much [ __ ]
yeah but hearing about netflix uh their
response
to the chappelle show that was awesome
yeah that was really because
i heard him on on the joe rogan
experience and and
he touched on that like joe rogan's oh
you know chappelle shows
on netflix now and they've just kind of
paused and he's smiling he's like yeah
but
i'm not i'm not making anything from it
and he just kind of left it at that
and so i was like what did that mean
like what do you mean he's not making
anything from it
and that i think was pro because this uh
stand-up special
on his instagram was what it took place
this past week or something
it was pretty recent pretty recent right
yeah so i'm guessing he shot that after
he did he did jre and then so
now getting the full context of it was
like oh that's what he was talking about
but
it's it takes dave chappelle to go out
and tell people and he has they have to
hear it from his mouth right
because i was even hearing stuff from
like i wasn't uh
the the radio show with charlemagne
what's that [ __ ] called oh the brilliant
idiot
not no no not brilliant okay ray look at
my
dude ray finally culture man
yeah so but you know i i think i you
know i could be misquoting this but you
know charlemagne and djm was like
he must be making a little bit of
something something you know and they
kind of put that out on the ether and
then
people might believe that [ __ ] but it
takes dave chappelle to come and say
actually i'm not making [ __ ] [ __ ]
because we think from our perspective he
has to nobody would do that right but
that's how [ __ ] cutthroat this
[ __ ] industry is too
yeah and it sucks too that you have to
have your wits about you because
somebody is always out looking for
themselves versus
versus you and they do a really good job
of making it sound like they're doing
something for you i've seen that happen
so many times you have
any idea how many times i've taken a
[ __ ] meeting somebody has either said
the words
oh you're the next biggest thing um uh
your ideas are the best
like you're so you have something
special we're gonna put you in something
i got something for you
shut the [ __ ] up you don't mean any of
that [ __ ] you have said that [ __ ] to so
many [ __ ] people it just comes out
your mouth like [ __ ] diarrhea
and i understand because a lot of them
too they're they're either on autopilot
or they're just looking out for their
jobs i have been in situations where i
have worked with other
specific networks and there's these
execs who have either slandered
slandered misconstrued stuff that i said
because they [ __ ] up
just to cover their back and i have to
go in through an email and be like hold
on a second
that's not how it [ __ ] is this is
what it's like because they're looking
out for their own
you know bunch of snakes though you know
i mean i think
um anybody who's had any experience in
the entertainment industry
is well aware of how many snakes there
are in the in the industry
whether you know it's music whether it's
whether it's hollywood whatever
right right and look like for me being
on the music side
how many times i've heard horror stories
of like just artists
new artists right who are just getting a
little buzz or whatever
who gets signed to a terrible [ __ ]
contract first of all
and then the label basically shelves
them and it's and it's like for a number
of reasons one might be
oh this artist or this group is starting
to garner some interest from
a competing label we don't want them to
pick them up
because that could be competition for us
so what we're going to do is we're going
to sign them but we have no intention of
putting this artist out
because they already have their artists
that they're pushing up yeah it's like
that's
it's a game to them it's just dollars
and cents you're monetizing these people
these are
just commodities and so they're not
looking at it from we respect your craft
and your artistry and what you're trying
to do
we want to help you propel your career
by giving the platform for that
that's why as much as i do have gripes
with like
current current ways of uh
consuming media like all the platforms
that exist whether it be your
youtube or tick tock or instagram
whatever right
i mean it's just too much but it does
provide an infrastructure for artists to
stay independent
and be able to propel their career
themselves yeah
now how you do that that's a whole
different topic
right because some people now are kind
of taking what the labels did
and and then putting into their own own
hands there's there's like this layer of
fakeness in that and they're doing that
just to play the game
which teach their own i can't i can't
knock on that if you're if you can sleep
at night
by by doing something like that by by
like putting out this fake persona or
fake image of you
your lifestyle your art whatever just to
make money
then so be it right but i'm saying
there's nobody saying
well even if you want to do that you
can't because
we own you you're under contract with us
so if you want to put out a project we
got to give you the green light
make a project let us know but then
they're not going to give you the money
necessarily maybe you might get a shitty
advance right like in the music scene
but you got to recoup that you got to
recoup that that was the craziest thing
that i found out yeah
you hear this stuff it's like yo this
folk got a multi-million dollar record
deal i was like that's
that's alone yeah they're like that's
what i found out they're like actually
that's
they're loaning you that [ __ ] for their
music but you gotta pay that back off
your tours everything else that's the
record
saying like the contract is so shitty
like
like the back end points they're getting
on stuff is like not
so it just takes forever for you to
recoup this and
while all the while labels making their
money right and then so like
that's why you've seen so many artists
too
who midway through like their contract
with the label
start lashing out like maybe they got a
five uh
five project album deal with the label
and then by their second or third
project
they're already like this big household
name but they're like i'm not making any
[ __ ]
these guys are jacking me but they're
making nothing yeah i want to get out of
this
they have to do merch other stuff
because that's where they make them
exactly
and that was kind of the shift we
started to see as far as the music
industry goes where like people started
to
try to traverse like that independent
route and then there there were
trailblazers within that too guys like
mclemore right ryan lewis and mac was
ryan lewis right that was his name ryan
lewis
uh it was they were those two combined
he was like the producing side yeah the
producer and macklemore i'm pretty sure
his name was ryan lewis
i could be complete i never liked his
music either way either way though
either way i mean but
i appreciated him though yeah yeah i'm
not like
the music i hate his [ __ ] i just never
really related to that [ __ ] you know
right so so there were
you know a lot of people who started
going down that route and then people
started to see like oh [ __ ] you know
what
i could make money too by being an
independent art i don't need to sign to
a major label isn't it a chance the
rapper is independent
yeah he is that's [ __ ] nuts he's like
grammy award with everything as an
independent artist how nuts is that but
but
obviously you got to have some like
business intelligence too like if you're
just on that oh i'm an artist tip and i
don't want to deal with that type of
yeah it ain't going to work it ain't
going to work
like in in this day and age if you
really want to take advantage of all the
tools available to you
you got to look at it from all angles
you have to be your own marketer you
have to be your own promoter you have to
be your own accountant you have to be
your own businessman
you have to be your own manager even you
know in some cases so you got to wear
all these different hats
i'm going
i'm not saying you got to do it i'm
saying the options are available to you
whereas let's say
15 years ago that wasn't the case there
was a lot of those it's funny because
that's that was very apparent even in
the youtube world
some of these artists who were waiting
on
other people like musicians specifically
that were waiting on other people to
record for them write their music
play do all this other stuff they
couldn't get anywhere in the beginning
stages of youtube because content was
being pushed out fast by people who were
so multifaceted
there's artists who could record their
own music they could mix and master
their own [ __ ]
and so if they wanted to do a cover they
can get it out within a couple days
three days versus other artists they're
waiting for somebody else to vocally
produce their
stuff and set it up i'm talking about
myself and then
you know so when they had when they had
that ability to do things
it was it was amazing and then i would
see certain artists who could do it and
they just wouldn't do it and i'm like
bro i wish i had your skill no for sure
for sure i mean
i was envious too like when i met z for
the first time right like oh yeah
yeah yeah he's all of our friend you
know
like he was probably the first person
where i
met where he could write his own [ __ ]
record his own [ __ ]
produce his own [ __ ] mix his own [ __ ]
and release his own [ __ ] everything yeah
and i was like
holy [ __ ] i'm like damn no you're doing
everything
yeah and i was envious of that because
cutting his own hair yeah
you know i gotta get it in there a
little bit a little ribbing uh i was
gonna step out but yeah i
like he was he was like the first um
person that i met where i i had a friend
who was able to do
everything and yeah that was really
amazing to me and i was like holy [ __ ]
man
i mean z is definitely worth every like
any time i do it
music right it was always with z and we
always split things 50 50.
yeah like nobody else does that because
i know he does a brunt of the work
so you know i obviously can sell the
record or get the listening and the
spins
yeah because i appreciate what he does
and i just split 50 50. i'm like
hey man i don't want to deal with
anything
yeah and and one thing too is that i
think
a lot of people take for granted is how
hard it is to be an engineer
like to sit there have people [ __ ] up
constantly but to have the patience
or even in some cases to guide them like
okay you know why don't we try it like
this i mean some people would snap
like within the first like [ __ ]
this is like your [ __ ] 20th take man
but the amount of patience and and you
know i've i've also heard stories or
seen cases too where engineers get
abused
you know like the artist just completely
taken for granted it's like dude
that's not an easy [ __ ] job oh it's
like that episode in atlanta where that
guy
his his session kept crashing in front
of that rapper
and he was like kind of looking at him
sideways like hey man but
don't have that [ __ ] happening yeah
right
right i remember i remember yeah yeah
but yeah
engineers it takes a certain type of
personality shout out to all the
engineers man you guys
you guys are doing good work you know
it's necessary work
but i feel like uh oftentimes uh they
don't get any shine or glory for
for the work that they do um but yeah i
mean
again it's just it's just uh goes to the
point of like
if you really want
to utilize all the tools and platform
that's available to you you can
you just got to have the drive to do
there's there's there's so many ways to
succeed
in this era yeah it's hard for me to
hear people who say i can't do it mm-hmm
that it's like man no you don't want to
do it yeah it's not you can't do it you
don't want to do it yeah there's there's
a very clear
fundamental difference between the two
yeah you have the tools
yeah but you're choosing not to use it
or you just suck yeah or you just suck
i mean but you know if you suck i mean
and you're trying i'm like hey
props for working hard but you just wack
hey sometimes it's hard it's hard when
when a lot of people just have other
people gas them up and they suck and
they've just been sucking for years
and i feel so bad like i've definitely
met a few people who have
given me like mixed tapes and you know
first of all i always get so confused
when somebody gives me their music i am
a stand-up comedian
what do you want from me they're giving
you roasting materials
like like yo man like i'm trying to make
it big out there yo can you listen to my
[ __ ] mixtape and i'm like who are you
talking to what am i i don't know like
don't [ __ ] send me this [ __ ] what
you're
trying
to do with this i know i'll definitely
put me on though i hate that's phrased
hey yo yo can you put me on real
about that quick [ __ ] you dude like why
don't you do it yourself don't ask me
don't ask people for a [ __ ] handout
it's like nahs because people haven't
heard me that's why i'm not shining it's
like no when i listen to the music i'm
like
it's not because of that you are garbage
but i get you so you should give me yeah
yeah it's like yo like you know what the
most obnoxious thing is too is when i
see somebody who does comedy
and you know comedy is very subjective
whether you find it funny or not sure
it's for sure
it's the most subjective thing out there
or like all right
all right you know so yeah when somebody
asked me to look at their comedy
and i'm like what did you expect from me
what do you want me to say they're like
yo
i feel like you and i are like the same
so i'm doing comedy too i was like
first of all i will i will stab you
don't ever say that
well not only that if they're asking you
for your opinion don't be mad if i give
you my opinion
you know like you're asking for it if it
sucks i'm gonna tell you what sucks
and it's like don't get [ __ ]
sensitive about that [ __ ]
like if you want to get better then be
open to criticism this is what i say too
i'm like
i don't think your [ __ ] is funny at all
like i said this one somebody was like i
find it not funny it's like you don't
see me laughing i don't find it funny
however
yeah it doesn't mean that you're not
going to not be successful right it's
just not funny to me
right right you know exactly i'm not
this like anr
development person too i don't know i
can't look at something
and say oh this can be successful in
this realm that's not where my mind goes
i just think is it funny to me if it's
not and they go oh [ __ ] should i change
it no don't base it on what i say yeah
find your own voice somebody will find
it funny there are so many
like great example right like uh our
buddy jason chen right jason chen does
these like tick tock
videos right i don't know oh you should
watch it it'll make you it'll make you
want to jump off the bridge
jason i [ __ ] love you but that your
your comedy is like the lowest hanging
fruit garbage i've ever seen in my life
oh it is comedy dumpster fire
dumpster fire like it's the worst [ __ ]
i've ever seen in my life however
that's from that's from the opinion of
of adults right right like young kids
look at his stuff and they go damn this
is like some mind-blowing comedy so it
affects somebody right like he did a
video where
it's like i had a dream that my girl i
had a dream that uh
i cheated on my girl and so the video is
his girlfriend on his back crying
don't leave me as he's vacuuming the
floor doing the dishes and i'm looking
this and i'm rolling my eyes
like who is liking this [ __ ] garbage
dude
but jason chen's a businessman and he
knows oh i bet you this will hit
somebody and it does make
somebody laugh out there like losers
obviously but
you know no you know but you know but
like i'm saying
that's how subjective it is right
because i know
everybody in my circle and peers above
the age of [ __ ] 14
thinks that's [ __ ] trash yeah you
know however
there's 300 400 000 views on it so
somebody finds it entertaining
so you can't base it on what i think
because there's one person for sure for
sure
and it's like you know for me too um
whenever like people would ask me for
opinion like especially when i was doing
music too and khalif knows this
i'd always give an honest opinion like
if i think you suck you suck but i
wouldn't
lie i would never say you need to stop
because of that i would never say
you suck so bad you should quit because
who the [ __ ] are we exactly i would say
keep working on your craft though right
yeah
no i'm not saying to you directly but
you know um
yeah like i would always just say like
this
for my wrapping days yeah
yes no but like yeah i'd always give my
honest
opinion and like critique it honestly
but then
i'd always be like yeah just continue to
work hard at it because
there might be an audience who actually
likes this [ __ ] now the audience might
be five people but it's still somebody
yeah it's still somebody not every
single person in this world is gonna say
this [ __ ] is whack somebody might listen
and be like wow i like that
so much and i'll be like you
[ __ ] are crazy
but if it works
it works like how many times have i seen
on instagram like i've had so many like
these like asian kids come up and they
go oh can you see my comedy and it's
like somebody doing
uh dressing up as an asian mom and
they're doing the asian mom joke and
it's like
80 of these guys doing it so crazy right
you know and it's like
i know where they learned it from yeah
and it's partially my fault yeah you
know
yeah but it's you know and i always tell
them too i'm like hey
you that shit's gonna run dry we did
that asian mom thing
once yeah twice and we moved on and we
started doing other stuff outside of it
but they're like oh this works i gotta
beat this horse until it's [ __ ] dead
and so they keep doing this joke and
they dress up as
an asian mom in every single video clip
is like yeah i had this thing where
i dress up as an asian mom and i say
stuff that asian moms say
funny what do you want me to say yeah
i guess it was funny yeah 12 years ago
is it still going to be funny now
probably not yeah and they see people
who are starting to lose interest in
their stuff and they start freaking out
and it comes from them to make new
content and they they're like oh [ __ ] i
don't have any content
i'm basing my content off of everybody
else's stuff i actually don't know how
to create
exactly and and that's that's the main
point is that
you have the originators the
trailblazers versus the culture vultures
the people who rip other people
and and again to like kind of circle
back to dave chappelle that
dave chappelle is an originator you know
he doesn't have to borrow from other
people
not to say that he hasn't been
influenced he's very clear yeah we we're
all
influenced yeah exactly you got to know
what's great you got to recognize what's
great in order
to meet it or surpass it right um but
yeah there's uh so many people who are
just uh
basically copying everybody else ripping
off what's popular
and you know what i'm not really going
to talk [ __ ] on that because
at the end of the day if there are
people who are consuming that
and and and encouraging them through
through views through
money right clicks you there's a demand
for it that's why that
demand is being filled and it's being
met and i know why there's a demand for
it
or in my personal opinion right it's
because there's a lot of people out
there
that look at what somebody else has and
they want what they have for
they don't have the skill to do it
exactly so they rather steal
and they want to take credit for other
people's work and then other people will
bolster that idea they go well why can't
they're just making people laugh and
enjoy life it's you know why it's
because you're also an untalented [ __ ]
and you want to be able to steal like
they do so you can't reprimand them for
stuff that you want to do yourself yeah
and so the i don't i do have a problem
with that because
people don't understand when it comes to
art and when it comes to thought and
creativity
it takes a lot from that individual to
create like that
and the moment that they do it and then
somebody steals it and takes credit for
them
it feels like you're taking a piece of
their [ __ ] soul yeah there was a
youtuber
who i mean she's probably doing well now
i heard she's doing music now her name
is uh gabby hannah right
i didn't even do a video about her but i
did this random video it was
oh so back this is a i'll we'll talk
about this on a podcast with justin
later so i did this
fake series back in the day where justin
and i would fight
all the time right just me and justin
chan so
i actually forgot to tell people that
those videos were fake right
and then one of the videos started
getting popular again and people were
just talking [ __ ] like yo
you should be able to take chris from
justin chan he's a famous director he
created all this stuff in [ __ ] and i'm
like
that video was fake like this is fake
and so what we were
we were actually prepping for [ __ ]
through those videos and we were gonna
do this whole thing where
actually the next video after that when
we were fighting in this restaurant
the video after that he was gonna smash
the windows in my car oh [ __ ]
and i was just going to pay for it you
know but then uh we decided to do [ __ ]
the film instead
it worked out right but in one of the
videos just casually as we were talking
um
that girl back in the day got got uh
[ __ ] roasted
because she stole louis ck's stand-up
[ __ ]
right and it was highly apparent and
what her excuse was well sometimes like
it just gets
those stuff that people you admire just
get stuck in and you just say i was like
no no no you stole it bit for bit
i understand when we make jokes with com
like comics that we like and it becomes
a part of our videos
but that only works as ev if everybody
knows you're making a louis ck video
you did the video as if it was yours
that's why people had a problem with it
i've been in my early videos i imitated
dave chappelle so [ __ ] much it was in
every but everybody knew
i was doing a dave chappelle joke and we
laughed together because they knew
that it was dave chappelle's stuff yeah
there's a clear reference there's a
clear reference it's me referencing his
jokes
and me saying dave chappelle likes stuff
versus me saying
this is my joke laugh at it she was
stealing a bit and she made a whole
video with louis c.k stuff
and and even his representation was
pissed like you
can't do that [ __ ] and so but a lot of
kids were defending or saying like well
if people are laughing why can't they
just laugh
it's like that's because you don't have
talent
you don't have anything to offer yet
because you haven't you've chosen not to
develop it
you have that ability but because you
want to be okay with people stealing
stuff because you want to be okay
with you doing it too and that's what i
have a problem with
you know so just to play devil's
advocate about that there's
the integrity side and like the honesty
side right just to like steal
somebody's material and then there's the
other half of it because like stealing
is one part
right you got to be able to now take
that and leverage it
right and then so like that also takes
some sort of skill too
in terms of like marketing it the right
way putting it out there the right way
the business
so like that's what i mean it's like you
have you got to have like these
combination of all these skills in order
to actually get a result that
might be close to what you're going for
or even meet what you're going for
and and and god willing exceed it and so
like
the stealing part i'm not saying is
right that's not what i'm saying is
right is what i'm saying is like
as long as there's a market where the
demand is
there and then they figure out a way to
basically meet that demand
now once that happens that artist should
get called out for
damn sure it like like in this case you
know uh
be reprimanded for that like louis ck
call or louis ck's representation
calling her out
other people calling around other comics
calling her out and then from there
people should recognize like okay that's
not their content
so whatever this person is known for
wasn't theirs
and then so like let's see what they do
next though right now now you have this
platform
and just as that platform can take you
high
it can get you crashing down 100 and you
know with her too like i i always so the
funny thing is
there's a funny story about that so
she act we actually have a mutual friend
and so she was pissed she was like
[ __ ] like i he was telling me she was
cursing up a storm saying [ __ ] that fat
boy whatever
she's fat too which is hilarious to me
right [ __ ] louis ck no to me
right [ __ ] fat on fat crime and [ __ ]
that's hilarious right
um in this video because she's all about
body positivity but she was over here
calling me a fat [ __ ] other people
like [ __ ] but you know i was like
whatever she's young i understand right
and once again i have nothing against
her and what i told when he was like he
this dude when he hit me up he was like
hey man uh
i'm just going to tell you this because
i know you're not going to do it but she
says she wants a formal apology from you
and he was laughing as he's telling me
this he was like i know you're not going
to do it
but i'm her friend and i told her i
would talk to you but this is as far as
i go you know because he knows me like
we're homie homies right and i'm like
okay and i was like well can you relay a
message to her right no this is very
nice i was like
she is the hottest like vine artist
whatever at the moment right
you are worried about the opinion of
sheep right now i was like
my platform has never ever been as big
as hers right
this is not a formal video about it this
is just a casual it was like almost
podcast like
right where we're just having this
conversation i have nothing personally
against her
but she did what she did it's a fact
it is not an opinion at this point it's
the fact you stole
the bid i'm not going on this crusade to
take her down
it was just something that we talked
about because it was just conversation
in the car
so what i'm telling her is that this is
going to pass
you because you're a young person you
could either apologize
for it or whatever or ignore it it's
going to go away the problem is just she
chose to put
power into it because she kept freaking
out about [ __ ] and you're ups and i'm
telling her
tell her to [ __ ] relax and not to
worry about somebody she played the
victim card after she stole
exactly you know what i mean i was like
what are you worried about you're
worried about the opinion of sheep
and at this point when it comes to the
creator space my opinion i'm sheep
compared to her
you have so much more fans than me you
have such a huge following don't [ __ ]
worry
don't ask somebody to come talk to me
[ __ ] if you want to come talk to me
come talk to me right and we'll and i'll
tell you the same thing
shut the [ __ ] up i don't care right yeah
and the more you egg me on the more i'm
just gonna drag you
right and guess what i could try to drag
you nothing's gonna happen
because i'm a [ __ ] nobody and so for
her
that's what i had to tell her and i was
like are you gonna tell him that he goes
i can't tell her that but
you know but i but i said to him too i
was like you know what she's
obviously very [ __ ] talented you know
she's gotten very far she didn't have to
steal that bit
because a lot of our other stuff are
originals right so you have the talent
you just made a poor choice and chose to
steal something
because you felt that you had to make so
much content you ran out of out of your
own content
and that you had to go to stealing
somebody else's [ __ ] so you are talented
you know what the [ __ ] you're doing you
have so much skill but you're worried
about stupid [ __ ] and you [ __ ] up
that's all that it is and move on you
know yeah so i like i mean i got no
context in the situation but you just
provided some context that that she
actually does have some talent she
didn't need to do it
she didn't have to yeah i mean that's
even worse the fact that
you have talent and maybe it's one of
those things though
where and and i'm not i'm not like
really trying to
you know be compassionate to like for
what she did but
maybe it was one of those things she was
also very young at the time oh i see so
like i i still
man i keep [ __ ] up with her too
though because i was on tim's
stream not too long ago and then we were
like streaming some [ __ ] right
and there was this book and i was
flipping through the book and it had
like random poetry and i was like the
[ __ ]
shit's garbage right and it was her book
and i was like [ __ ] man
i didn't mean to reignite that i was
like
[ __ ] i'm kidding you know i didn't know
it was hers yeah you know i was just
making a joke because it was
it was drawing it was just a prop yeah
it was just a prop i was making a joke
and i'm like
and then tim just starts dying laughing
because he knows about this thing he's
like it's gabby hannah's and he starts
crying laughing i'm like [ __ ] him stop
laughing this makes me look terrible you
know i wasn't i didn't specifically know
but once again this this even this
part's never going to get to her
unless some addictive [ __ ] is going to
say but she's like i said she's [ __ ]
talented like she does music now too she
writes her own [ __ ]
she has the skill and ability to be an
entertainer and like it's very much
appreciated
however when you steal [ __ ] and
especially when it comes to comedy world
and i came from stand up
it is going to bother me right right you
know and i am good i didn't go on like i
said i didn't go on a crusade
to tarnish her name but it was just a
thought of it like own up to it you know
what i'm you know what you did
you know what you did yeah you just
gotta [ __ ] just apologize and move on
you know yeah it is what it is man but a
lot of these like younger youtubers were
so
that's why they have this quote-unquote
youtube beef which me bart and joe would
always laugh about
right they go yo i got beef with this
[ __ ] so what you gonna scrap
you guys gonna throw down what are you
gonna do like what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do
have you guys even seen each other in
person yeah or is it just digital
spit spat you know back and forth [ __ ]
right yeah because like in our mind too
i think it's because of the way that we
grew up you know especially with people
dying people get shot and killed it's
like
this isn't beef yes if it was beef you'd
be dead yeah beef has a certain like
connotation yeah
i mean like if you say you got beef with
somebody like oh you got down with this
nah he just said something bad about me
he's like the [ __ ]
somebody somebody years ago sent me this
funny [ __ ] video
and it's this uh like there's a lot of
these like younger
creators that i don't really know
because uh i'm not the avid i'm not an
avid youtube watcher anymore right like
i've been on the space for 11 years now
so
obviously i'm not going to be as into it
as when i was like 23 or or whatever
right
so uh [ __ ] i don't want to [ __ ] up his
name because it sounds super
disrespectful
the first part is uh it's either it's an
asian ass [ __ ] word
it's it's either rice gum or rice bum
but it's one of those things that's
ricegum rice gun yeah right no is it
rice gum
gum gum rice gum yeah apologies
you [ __ ] dweeb no i'm kidding no i'm
kidding but this kid rice
rice rice jump right so rice i'm kidding
so this kid ricegum yeah somebody sent
me a video of his
and apparently he had beef with some
other dude on youtube and they're
recording as they're confronting him and
then
this kid rice comes a very loud
flamboyant kid he's like whatever six
feet tall super skinny but he
he kind of does these quote-unquote
rants right and
i guess he was talking mad [ __ ] and they
brought up the video to him and they
were approaching him right he comes up
to him and he goes hey what's up man
and i'm like wait i thought you didn't
like this guy
right i'm saying like oh no she's a
publicity stunt for the youtube yeah and
i bring that point up because
that's not beef this is all you guys are
playing [ __ ] uh patty cake with each
other
right so when you say beef you guys
could go always go ahead and settle it
like [ __ ] man-to-man and go ahead and
or talk to each other face to face again
that that goes back to the point i made
earlier of now
these content creators are doing what
the
the bigger guys would do to create
interest to create like
people like logan paul yeah yeah the guy
the
the the the black british dude yeah yeah
yeah kkkdi
or something like that yeah yeah and
then i know his name yes
ksi ksi yeah so ksbsi yeah
you know so and they made like what four
mil ten mil off of that boxing match
it's [ __ ] insane it was like one of
the worst boxing matches i've ever seen
in my life but it doesn't matter
yeah and that's a great comparison to
what we have with um it's like
watered-down content but it's appealing
to a certain crowd yeah these guys are
capitalizing off
for sure first i'm sure man there's a
lot more going on that
people don't know about in terms of like
these so-called
beefs or dramas that exist within like
the social media
platforms or the content creators on
those respective platforms
um and and you know they're just doing
it to make money yeah
i bet you if you talk to them in person
they're probably like super nice people
dude
they're just you know young people and
they get caught up in the hype and they
feel like they have to push a certain
persona because they're afraid that
they're going to be forgotten tomorrow
because i know what that feels like to
be in a space where you feel like you
constantly have to create
and if you don't create you feel like
your identity is based on how
that thumbs up button that like button
that view yeah if you don't get that you
don't feel validated as a human being
especially at that age when you're 20
years old 18 year old 19
and you have [ __ ] seven figures in
your bank account and you know for a
fact that that money's in there simply
because you do
crazy [ __ ] yeah and you have to keep one
upping it one upping
it and then you see somebody else come
up and then you're forgotten because
they're doing
doing crazier [ __ ] than you it's it's
hard
to deal with for a lot of these young
kids sure especially because at that age
they don't even know who the [ __ ] they
are yet i actually feel bad for them
they don't know who the [ __ ] they are
yet they don't even have real friends
yet at this point
so what is their foundation they think
that they have this idea of what
friendships and real relationships are
and they find out oh these people are
just using me because they want to make
their own money and then when they
become successful they leave me
so now their guards are up and now they
start going crazy and this isn't
speculation i
know specific people in this space that
broke down like that because they didn't
take the time to invest in
invest in themselves and they got
popular too fast at a young age like
fouseytube right
fouseytube is a great example right um
tim recently did a podcast with them and
he was telling me
and so a little backstory between me and
you seth so yousef and i actually met
youssef i was one of the first people he
met when he came to l.a
me and abe met him right really sweet
dude
uh he's he's dealt with a lot of these
like mental issues for a very long time
um and with him he was one of those
cases like he always created for other
people
i didn't watch tim's podcast but this is
just my opinion
youssef's biggest issue was that he is
the clear example of that
he never ever created for himself he
always looked to see what was popular
what everybody else liked
about the stuff that he was going to
create so he created for everybody else
but himself just anything that generates
clicks and views
exactly and so when it came time for him
to create for himself
either people didn't like it or he
didn't know if it was good because the
likes and the like ratio and the view
count
didn't represent what he felt about his
products right right
you know and like that's such a slippery
slope because your identity
starts morphing because of that like
this is supposed to be
like the real platform now right you get
to see the real
how how whoever this person is who are
you but then you're catering to a
specific
thing i am who you say i am yeah exactly
and then now you're like
trying to be quote unquote real like man
it's [ __ ] whack
yeah yeah that's the real me
yeah that's like that's the real yeah
like this fool got his head tattooed
to fill in his hairline and [ __ ] doing
all this other stuff this will
like clearly he he might have been on
roids for a second or something but just
watching this guy just burn in front of
me you know
yeah and he when i met him anyways
super nice guy but emotionally very
volatile and he came into a space where
being an emotionally volatile human
being is the worst
it's the [ __ ] worst because no matter
what he does either he's going to be
praised or crucified but it's always on
the hard end of each spectrum
yeah either i [ __ ] love you or i
[ __ ] hate you and then he started
getting a god complex when he's when he
wanted to throw that
that drake concert or whatever he's like
yeah drake's coming through didn't
happen
people started flaming him for that [ __ ]
put him into a spiral of depression
and what do you say about that bro it's
like you were fine with who you are
people liked you and you weren't okay
with it because you
you just kept doing stuff for other
people try to go bigger and better
you know [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude yeah be
broke like me
man i'm happy i mean but
that's that's the slippery soap about it
and then what i alluded to earlier
you you can go bigger and better but the
fall can be
pretty [ __ ] hard man no um
mediocrity is the best bet i don't know
about that
hey man you know what this will [ __ ]
up earlier too we were talking about
dave chappelle right and i was like yo
man how did
how does somebody become like dave
chappelle like some people got it some
people don't and i'm like bro i'm
standing right here
he's like dissing me right now it's like
some people just hate me
analogy i made is like hey man you got
guys like mj and kobe right
there's a bunch of other professional
basketball players why are they not mj
and kobe
they're just sitting here just like bro
just [ __ ] tell me i suck
trash in the [ __ ] out now i just tell
you like it is like i said
i just say it like it is right yeah
that's opinion yes yeah like even with
that kid
uh uh that [ __ ] logan paul right
that guy i don't know what goes on as is
that you know that guy popped off
hard dude he's the biggest star in on
youtube now even till this day
more than pewdiepie i thought pewdiepie
was isn't he the the would you say
i don't think that's how you say his
name pewdiepie pewdiepie
we're gonna change his podcast
yo this [ __ ] pogba
this is an episode of old heads uh well
we can't pronounce nothing
pewdiepie pewdiepie yeah i said rice
bum man i might have said that in an old
video too
hey hey that's no disrespect to you
young man i haven't really even watched
a contest
hasn't been like reigning number one for
like forever maybe
you know these guys are so interesting
maybe it's because like i don't have a
uh
a yearn to be on a space and be
recognized once i make like a gajillion
dollars
you would never see me i would disappear
right like
chappelle disappear for years and i'll
come back saying crazy [ __ ]
how crazy was it going back to chappelle
when you watched unforgiven when he was
saying like
on his first night doing a show and the
guy was like you might see someone
become a star introducing dave chapple
he told that story before though yeah
yeah yeah so mario wasn't too bad yeah
some yeah because [ __ ] muriel we were
i was watching
uh chappelle the chappelle show on
netflix
and she goes who's dave chapple and i
looked at her i was like get the
[ __ ] out of his house i was like i would
you don't know me
i would have had the exact same reaction
it's like did you watch she said to a
friend exactly she goes did you watch
the chapel show oh
shamble shackle dude
chapel sounds like the name of a white
racist pastor dude
and i just was i'm like i didn't even
say anything at first yeah because i
couldn't process what was good
and that would be dumbfounded at first
too later on we were just laying in bed
and it was just quiet and i looked over
i said do you know who michael jordan is
yeah she goes yeah who's michael jackson
she goes yeah how the [ __ ] do you know
she goes i don't know everything i was
like that's not that's a household
name that's like i said you don't know
what water is yes come on now
dave chapel and jeff does she know who
she
is engaged to that's that's the thing
too i sometimes i wonder she goes
you know what you make too much jokes
[ __ ]
like this
so what you what you mean i mean you
guys should be saying something hurtful
[ __ ] she'll stop when she's mad at me or
look at me yeah with the weird pot she
goes
you know you're not that funny and i'm
like oh god man
oh my god i hate you so much you try to
say [ __ ] that hurts my feelings
oh yeah like okay man i'm gonna put that
pillow over your face at night though
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast
shout out to my fiance uh saying dave
chappelle uh appreciate that a lot
i still love you guys together mario
come on now shout out to ray for saying
about
for uh correcting kalief earlier
on instagram you can find ed at ed2 and
at secret society
uh black friday sale because this video
is going to go out this thursday oh okay
bf50 we're doing our biggest promotion
yet get 50
off the entire site get ready
yeah we got the k-town collection still
there we got some of our basic tees we
got all that other stuff
all the classics everything i'm wearing
right now you get fifty percent off if
it's not enough
take that [ __ ] and then so we can hurry
up and start a new line
uh help us out please see y'all next
time peace